bonsoir oui merci d'être avec nous alors
bonsoir que dit cette visite de ces
chefs de la diplomatie européens que le
pays est en voie de normalisation
oui ce sont des signes en fait positif
il ya marathon le président queille
saïda s'est rendu à tripoli a rencontré
son homologue libyen a lui même fait la
même chose le président libyen le
président du conseil et ministre libyen
s'est rendu à en egypte a rencontré à
traiter à 6 6 et 3 ministres des
affaires étrangères européens sont
aujourd'hui à tripoli
62 bon signe en même temps on n'entend
pas les armes ne tombent pas la voir des
arbres on n'entend pas les militaires
les milices c'est une politique
maintenant et le diplomate qui priment
sur les militaires ce sont des bons bon
signe espérons que ça va continuer mais
malgré tout la libye actuellement est
divisée entre est et ouest et la ligne
du cirque jusqu'au jeux fra partage réel
mots et militairement la libye entre
deux cons alors on va en parler de ces
deux pendant quelques minutes mais mais
restons sur cette visite des européens
comment analyser la déclaration d'
emmanuel macron propos des libye nous
avons une dette envers la libye très
clair une décennie de désordre dit il
c'est le même regret que barack obama
avant de partir avant de quitter la
maison blanche a exprimé son regret et
l'a dit la libye et plonger dans le
chaos et je regrette
et aujourd'hui c'est la même chose c'est
parce que le même discours qui se
répètent sans des bonnes paroles moi je
trouve ça assez
c'est un pas positif mais il faut dire
que cette décennie noire pour le public
c'est une décennie de da a chassé le
shah baldé des islamistes des
terroristes d une déchirure
des dizaines de milliers de victimes les
biens et l'économie qui s'est effondré
donc le peuple libyen a beaucoup
souffert a beaucoup se faire et je pense
les bonnes paroles ne peut pas à
confronter réconforter le drame d'une
décennie d'une population qui est la
population libyenne mais mais ça reste
un signe positif comme barack obama l'a
dit avant de partir avant l'été la
maison
gauche alors on sait que la france hélas
l'italie sont très impliqués et on sait
aussi que c'est une route privilégié à
une route migratoire privilégié vers
vers l'europe ce qui explique cela oui
l'italie déjà l'un des très bons
rapports avec la libye même pendant la
réunion de gaddafi l'aï beaucoup de
contrats et elle est l'italien colisée
aussi la libye nous n'oublions pas ça et
je pense que l'allemagne aussi à jouer
un rôle à berlin dans la conférence de
l'est bien je pense à partir de la
conférence de berlin
les libyens ont commencé sérieusement
cette fois ci de trouver un chemin afin
de trouver une solution politique et
durable d'union nationale c'est à partir
de cette conférence de berlin donc
l'allemagne a joué un grand rôle
la france aussi l'italie aussi et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de facteurs
positifs aujourd'hui que d'autres se
regroupent afin de trouver solution
pacifique et permanente pour les libyens
parce que les libyens ont beaucoup
beaucoup ce faire j'ai beaucoup d'amis à
tripoli ou à benghazi et unique spring
toujours toujours leur chagrin il
n'exprime toujours leurs souffrances
alors parmi les pistes de stabilisation
du pays est évidemment la réunification
vous en parlais tout à l'heure entre
l'est et l'ouest 1 qui sont portées par
le nouveau gouvernement d'union
nationale on peut y croire à cette
réunification selon vous au blond le
progrès opérationnels c'est très
difficile
l'expérience la rentrée parce qu'on a eu
une ou des seigneurs de guerre
ils sont enrichis grâce à cette guerre
civile à l'est nous savons bien qu'il
allait à l'armée nationale les guerres
composé d'un plupart des officiers de
gaddafi mais dirigé par le maréchal
kraft à l'ouest plusieurs islamistes la
plupart sont des islamistes des milices
islamistes surtout à tripoli elias
interne aussi à l'ouest de l'île à
thomas au sud donc les protagonistes
armées sont nombreux surtout à l'ouest
et excuse et comment on comment faire
comment comment fait construire l'état
les biens il faut avoir le monopole de
la violence légitime comédie max weber
ça veut dire une seule armée nationale
et celle police
nationale mais que faire comment faire
la tâche est très très difficile et
hardy d'ailleurs monsieur habib beye
parler d'un miracle devant le parlement
les quatre blocs l'addition arrive à
unifier les institutions libyennes aient
déjà fait un miracle parce que les
cautions peu la tâche est très très
difficile sur le terrain
est ce que les militaires les milices
vont céder leurs armes facilement
j'ai des forts doutes alors on le
retrait des forces étrangères ont
réclamé par les états unis et des
européens à ce qu'elles sont
primordiales pour accélérer le processus
de paix absolument absolument parce que
les ingérences étrangères les
interventions des forces militaires
étrangères
ils ont aggravé la situation libyenne
notamment l'arrivée de l'armée turque à
tripoli
la turquie a envahi carrément tripoli ou
s'il ya d'autres présences au parle des
conseillers militaires égyptiens à l'est
ou du numéro 10 où même une présence aux
russes mais mais évidemment les plus
dangereux sont les terroristes les
intégristes qui sont venus avec la de
l'armée turque est souvenu de la syrie
parce que nous la poser le temps à poser
toujours les questions où sont ils
passés les terroristes deux dash de
reclasser de mousson certaines molière
peut pas mal se sont en libye
actuellement
merci à riadh sidaoui expérimentera
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france